Чи будемо ми подорожувати в майбутньому ось так?
З екстремальним прискоренням?
Принаймні перший тест-драйв Hyperloop з людьми на борту відбувся успішно.
Пізніше капсули будуть мчати по трубах зі швидкістю до 1200 кілометрів на годину.
Думаю, що ми будемо їздити в гіперлупі через кілька років.
Час у дорозі різко скоротиться.
У США у гіперлупі з Клівленда до Чикаго потрібно лише 28 хвилин - нині це 90 хвилин на літаку.
Але експерти попереджають.
Може статися саботаж або теракт. Це легко.
Багато запитань досі без відповіді.
Hyperloop - це просто дороге задоволення чи все ж революція у транспорті?
Ідея в Ілона Маска виникла у 2013-му.
Річард Бренсон вклав багато грошей, а Джефф Безос не має до цього жодного відношення.
HyperloopTT з Каліфорнії - перспективний стартап.
800 співробітників по всьому світу. 31 мільйон доларів стартового капіталу.
Але спочатку потрібно отримати дозвіл на використання нової технології. І цього ще не сталося.
Є проблема з неврегульованістю. Технологія іноді з’являється раніше, ніж законодавчі норми.
Ми дуже старанно працюємо. Ми - перша компанія, яка розробляє повний цикл експлуатації.
Зрештою якщо немає нормативно-правової бази, ми не можемо ані переміщувати людей у гіперлупі, ані перевозити товари.
Будівництво трас для гіперлупа вкрай дороге.
Один кілометр коштує близько 60 мільйонів доларів.
Запланований в Індії маршрут від Пуни до Мумбаї має проходити під землею,
що ще більше здорожує будівництво, але зменшить ризик можливих терактів.
Будівництво обійдеться у вісім мільярдів доларів США. Такі суми лякають інвесторів.
Ми показали, що Hyperloop можна фінансувати приватними коштами,
розраховуючи на період окупності близько 25 років і не покладаючись на державні субсидії.
Підрахунок ґрунтувався на тому, що ціна квитка становила приблизно 75 відсотків вартості фактичних квитків
для тих самих пасажирів в інших видах транспорту.
Подорож у космос має багато спільного з поїздкою на гіперлупі.
Космонавти і капсула оточені вакуумом.
У трубі теж вакуум, тому опору повітря немає.
Це дозволяє здійснювати особливо швидкі подорожі.
Але якщо капсула розгерметизується, пасажири помруть за лічені секунди.
Жодна з лабораторій Hyperloop поки не має рішення цієї проблеми, навіть німецька з Мюнхена.
Капсула тоді повинна дуже швидко загальмувати.
Пасажирам також слід дати кисневі маски, як у літаку.
Це всі варіанти, які можна розглянути.
Звичайно, якщо зусилля занадто затратні, це знову ж таки економічно невигідно.
Система не може бути успішною, якщо я маю серйозні проблеми з безпекою
або якщо мені доводиться встановлювати дуже дорогі системи для їхнього вирішення.
Отже, Hyperloop залишається лише красивою мрією? Ні, сподіваються перевізники.
Вантажні перевезення, безперечно, легші за пасажирські,
тому що вимоги безпеки нижчі, адже ви не перевозите людей.
Порт Гамбурга хоче використати ці ноу-хау і працює над новими концепціями, щоб швидше доставляти контейнери вглиб країни.
Hyperloop не для коротких маршрутів.
Hyperloop призначений для середніх і довгих відстаней - понад 300 кілометрів углиб країни.
Ось, що ми маємо на увазі. Поєднати два справді великі хаби, між якими курсує багато контейнерів.
І щоб це також було надійно протягом тривалого періоду часу. Тоді Hyperloop буде виправданим.
Нині насамперед мають бути побудовані реальні тестові траси довжиною в кілька кілометрів,
у тому числі з поворотами, що становить справжній виклик для Hyperloop через його високу швидкість.
Лише так він міг би довести свої переваги на великих відстанях.
У будь-якому випадку хайп навколо Hyperloop ще триватиме.